just gotta fall asleep in my hand a
little bit
[Music]
just drop a little bit
relax
[Music]
to be very gentle with her but also you
want to make sure that you
get the adjustment so all the way out
buddy there you go
holy moly so people think i'm just
cracking bones and that's scary so but
it's not
okay it's these little nitrogen oxygen
co2 bubbles dispersing and cracking okay
so when i really get that adjustment in
these little gas bubbles
release from the joint causing that
little cracking noise
[Music]
there's people who don't crack because
they're so damn tight stiff
stressed injured so those people it
takes me a little bit more time i got to
be more aggressive with those patients
to get some some
motion you know motion's life life is
motions so it's kind of like exercise
you want to make sure
your spine is also moving properly so
that your body is functioning better
completely let it sink in so i bring up
this hip
just like this that was nice it's all
about that
oh yeah drop that shoulder a little bit
just a little
come on relax for anybody
good stuff i get asked you know people
are more crunchier than the others
it doesn't really mean anything it just
means that you're getting more gas
release out of those joints
your joints are more mobile and that's
the whole phenomenon behind
why people are more crunchier than
others all right
relax
[Music]
we're always going through stresses in
life you know
sitting money financial issues
relationships i mean these are all
stresses in life
that need to be taken care of by good
adjustments in the spine to make you
feel better
to relieve tension off of the body
thinking
[Music]
um
so my instagram page i started that
probably two years ago people love the
crack
the reason being is because it's
satisfying as hell you know when i watch
it i feel like i feel it i feel more
relieved when i hear a good neck crack
or a back crack it's just
it's oddly satisfying so i'm just going
to keep going with it you know and
people are loving it
yeah let it fall right into my hand
there you go
so just it's like it's really nice and
easy
it's brought me a lot of awareness that
people do need chiropractic care and
i've seen thousands of patients you know
so
it's been a blessing and i love what i
do
you